welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki released its first
official trailer at disney's investor
day
new marvel stuff thank god a trailer so
mischievous and
ragnaroky cannonballing into the lore of
marvel history
and the unresolved mysteries of real
world history
turns out baby cooper wasn't on draper
it was loki which makes me
so damn excited for everything else
we're gonna attribute to the god of
mischief
santa equals loki probably now i reacted
to this glorious trailer and my reaction
spree in the
past 12 hours now we gotta break this
thing down
frame by frame because there are a ton
of easter eggs like think about it folks
i got nine minutes out of two seconds
back in february imagine what i can do
now
let's get started the trailer opens with
familiar shots of avengers end game when
the avengers revisited loki's arrest
during the time high spot tony stark
butterfingered the tesseract allowing
loki to escape
now we see where he went through a
bifrost-esque blast through space
now we even end it by passing through
what looks like the eye of heimdall as
past trips to the bifrost have appeared
to do it's interesting to see the
tesseract function similarly to the
bifrost because until now they have been
at least two different forms of magic in
the mcu
one in infinity stone the other all
father magic that both do the same thing
allow teleportation from anywhere in the
universe but this bifrost imagery
suggests to me that those two magics
might
really be linked as many of us have
suspected odin did possess
that tesseract for millennia and
according to children's books in the
thor movie he only crossed that rainbow
bridge when he was bringing the
tesseract to norway back in the old days
so maybe odin derived that bifrost power
from that stone oh look at me going on
about the technicalities of the science
of the mcu when there's a whole trailer
to break down
yeah i got it odin i'm moving on
okay loki has crashed landed in what i
assume to be the gobi desert of mongolia
based on the people who come across him
now i mentioned this in the reaction but
loki's crash in the dune
definitely evokes tony stark's crash
landing after escaping that cave in
afghanistan
the moment mr stark followed plato's
allegory of the cave to escape his
narrow world view to a place of
enlightenment as loki is now given a
second chance at life to do but it's
interesting that loki
crashed he is an experienced bifrost
traveler and with the space stone he
should have nimbly navigated to whatever
destination he wanted to go but he
doesn't appear to have the tesseract
anymore here so either this is from a
different scene
or something interfered with that travel
knocked the tesseract away from him
causing him to crash out at the nearest
mongolian off-ramp next clip
you're taking me somewhere to kill me
okay the marvel studios title card
appears in a
sea of l's o's k's and i's all different
typefaces like the ones that flicker at
the end i'll get to those
it's a really cool way to show the
countless alternate timelines and
historical causalities this series will
play with it also reflects the way
loki's remains would have been left
in the main mcu timeline if you think
about it floating in space among
hundreds of dead asgardians but then we
find ourselves in this elevator shaft of
what i seem to be the tva
time variants authority aka marvel's
time cops
actually that sounds cooler than it is
really the tva is like a bureaucracy of
timeline monitors
they oversee and investigate violations
across the various marvel timelines they
hate
kang the avengers meddled with the
timelines
big time in in-game but loki as the
escapee from one of those medlin
he would be the evidence of those
violations that the tda can now detain
actually the real world location here is
the eye popping infinity mirror looking
floors of the marriott marquee in
atlanta and i love how it implies each
floor is a kind of different
timeline in the multiverse with the
floor buttons each represented with a
three
character alphanumeric code j3e iul
fe3 lk3 2w1 fhf
vg2 u77 te7 gye
2we 3fg cet xn1
tsl gf3 if there is a rhyme or reason to
these it's too soon to tell i'm sorry
really just because it's chaos not all
of them have numbers but
the fact that there are three characters
is worth noting
because if you think about it they're
going through different realities maybe
each floor designates the three
coordinates of
three axes in space x y and z three
dimensions
but the elevator moves across these and
if you think that would be
a fourth dimension the axis of time
the one axis that connects
three-dimensional space in einstein's
theory of relativity am i breaking your
brain i'm sorry
really the more interesting thing to
look at are the symbols down the middle
there is a circle with a line going
through it ghostbusters style
an x three parallel lines and then a
little happy face
perhaps these directs how this time
wonkavator travels across those
timelines
it could stop or freeze a timeline dead
in its tracks it could crisscross
timelines it could reset timelines to
run parallel without interference
and then one where it's just like
surprising let me know who you think
these are let's move on
no i'm taking you someplace to talk well
i don't like to talk
but you do like to lie which you just
did
because we both know you love to talk
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say
you know time passes differently here in
the tva what does that mean
you'll catch up okay loki is detained as
a prisoner in this he wears a tva
jumpsuit and this collar i believe that
says danger maybe
explosive color he is with owen wilson's
character the closed captions reveal his
name to me
mobius m mobius love it that name is
actually the most recurring manager of
the tva in the comics they all have
goofy names the name mobius does come
from the same impossible geometric
shape that tony stark conceptualized to
crack the code of time travel in the
endgame
this time in the shape of a mobius strip
inverted please and mobius uses some
subtle wordplay of his own here
time passes differently here in the tva
what does that mean
you'll catch up yeah mobius isn't just
saying loki will
learn how their perception of time
travel works but he is saying that he
will literally
catch up from loki aging normally to
being beyond
time itself and the fact that mobius is
about to show him the end
of his timeline in an alternate life are
you confused
you'll catch up
[Music]
so chrono monitors enter this tent look
at the background there is someone
wearing elizabethan garb it looks like
this could be just a red
fair but since we know this show is
hopping through time
i think these chrono monitors are
hunting down a time fugitive and i think
the one they seek
is this hooded figure who drops the
lantern attacks the chrono monitor in
the reaction i speculated this could be
someone like doctor doom since richard e
grant is going to be playing some kind
of villainous character in this show
but based on this person's hands i think
this could be sophia di martino's
character who i speculated in a set
photo breakdown earlier this year
could be lady loki based on a comic when
loki's soul was transferred to a female
body after the comics ragnarok event
maybe there is an alternate timeline
where loki is in a female form and that
is the maniac that this loki now has to
try to hunt down and stop in a plea deal
to clear his criminal record with the
tva
stop the even more evil version of
yourself and you can walk free but
before i continue thank you to
honey for sponsoring this video with the
holidays coming up and all of us
spending more time
inside online shopping is the way to go
this year that is where today's sponsor
honey comes in
and boy does it honey is the free
browser extension that scours the
internet for coupon codes and then
automatically tests them when you're
checking out so here's how it works you
get honey on your computer for free
in two easy clicks and then you are
checking out on one of its 30 000
supported sites honey pops up and all
you have to do is click
apply coupons you just wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
for that site
if honey finds a working code you'll
just watch the prices drop
i recently bought a set of giant yard
dice from sharper image for a family
member that loves outdoor games
and honey found me a code for free
shipping that saved me almost
11 bucks those of you who have already
installed honey using my link
have found over 440 000
in savings you could be one of those
lucky people
it's simple if you have a computer honey
should be on it it's free and it works
with whatever browser you use
get honey for free today by going to
joinhoney.com
new rockstars that's joinedhoney.com new
rockstars so they know i sent ya and
again thanks honey for sponsoring
today's video
moving on
[Music]
[Applause]
so loki is brought before this awesome
looking courtroom three looming faces
and this judge that is played by gugu
mubathara
she could be one of the known justices
of the tba there's justice peace justice
love justice goodwill but those three
faces i believe are the same faces that
we see in the giant statues in the
interior courtyard
i'm wondering if these figures could be
connected to the
multiple faces multiple identities of
the living tribunal
the cosmic deity judge that oversees the
universe like perhaps the living
tribunal is the chief justice who
oversees
these lower level appellate court
justices because notice behind loki you
can see on the wall it reads
three time court time court meaning
there are
other types of court these aren't just
the tva courts in this building so
there's probably some higher level judge
overseeing other kinds of cosmic crimes
also notice how later in the trailer she
and the chrono monitors brandished these
batons
these reminded me of the staff of the
living tribunal that mortar showed
doctor strange and comartaj
this is the staff
of the living tribunal otherwise why
would you use a simple baton like this
why would that be the weapon of choice
now the floors of this facility contain
vast stacks of books which is another
interesting parallel with commentary if
think about it that confined all of its
mystic cosmic multiversal wisdom into
tangible book hard copies mobius and
loki used his projector to
beam up loki from past mcu moments his
arrest in the first avengers movie which
this loki would have just experienced
but also
this famous loki pose which he actually
makes in ragnarok
your savior is here
which is odd because this loki would not
have
lived that yet ragnarok was like five
years after this this
tells us that mobius is showing loki how
his life
would have played out in that alternate
timeline and notice when loki turns away
uncomfortable we can assume that mobius
is showing him his
death in the grip of thanos and infinity
war a moment i too have used to trigger
some cringes
i'm sorry
okay here chrono monitors approach this
rox cart store in the pouring rain
based on the rain this is probably the
scene that we saw the set photos of
earlier this year
roxcart has the same roxx suffix as
roxanne
the energy conglomerate that has
appeared in the background of past
marvel films i'm wondering if that oil
company might have branched out in the
future
into retail like other science fiction
has shown you know the futuristic
by-and-large store that ruined earth and
wally notice these troopers appear to
come from these glowing doors
these could be the portals through which
they travel through time or maybe that's
what those elevator doors look like on
the other side
now watching them on the security
monitors appears to be that same hooded
figure that we saw earlier again i do
think that's dimartino possibly lady
loki whom we know from set photos was
part of this sequence but notice
near patio goods is that roaming robot
maybe it's a waistband or a floor
cleaner or even a futurey version of
those creepy robots that stacks up and
reports spills that exists in
supermarkets right now hate those things
they always look at me when i write
cookie dough i know you're just going to
eat it raw
shut up loki lands back in this elevator
door-lined room
frustrated as if he just tried to escape
the tva but then was just circled right
back to the starting point now this red
gate and the floor underneath it have
these blast streaks this could be the
portal that activates
where in time these elevator doors take
you and if you like i love how the
portal is just powered by a tangled mess
of wires everything's so bureaucratic
and messy and stupid it's awesome and
douglas adamsy now there is a brief shot
that i find interesting mobius is
receiving some kind of item maybe a
watch from this young child
this could be lady loki as a young girl
and that stained glass behind them
depicts some demonic figure this could
be mephisto folks who is rumored to
appear in
one of these upcoming phase four titles
but then there is this insane
shot of a moon crashing down on a
planet's surface i'm wondering if this
could be connected to thanos spiking the
moon an infinity war obviously this
isn't the same moon and this planet
doesn't look like titan
but you know that purple glow definitely
reminds me of the way he used the purple
power stone energy to shatter that moon
before he threw it either way sitting
below
waiting for this death melancholia style
by a pair of runoff pipes some believe
this was natasha romanov no no no this
is sophia diontino's character maybe we
are seeing her at the very end of her
timeline
after the universe has just been wiped
out next clip
brother i'm down okay here we see loki
standing up in the midst of a similar
post-apocalyptic chaos but that
is devastated new york behind him
including avengers tower
i'm thinking loki could be popping into
a dark alternate timeline in which
thanos's first wave of attack on new
york when loki led the chitauri fleet
was actually successful and then we see
the airport with cops watching as a bag
of money is transferred to this flight
attendant as loki watches on in shades
yes loki is db cooper here in case you
don't know who db cooper is he is the
infamous
mystery man if that was even his name in
1971 he extorted a 200 000
ransom and he hijacked northwest orient
airlines flight 305
from portland to seattle and then he
parachuted out
and was never found all they found of
them was a few banknotes found in the
columbia river i love this story and i
love that loki is digging into it
because it suggests to us that this
series
is going to use loki's time hopping to
justify
all these crazy mysteries of human
history maybe they're going to say all
the mandela effect occurrences that have
come up whether the berenstein bears or
sinbad being in a genie movie all of
these could have just been caused by
loki's rifts in the timeline there's a
really cool one of these that comes up
at the end of the trailer stay tuned
loki then runs on the surface of that
same purple planet as the moon looms
down on them
toward this interesting looking shack it
is stamped with the number 21
now his jacket reads variant maybe the
tva agents have to wear certain clothes
when they explore these variant
timelines like the adjustment bureau
with that hat rule
and then loki swings this woman around
this setting does look familiar to me
the architecture is similar to kamartage
though those are roman numerals behind
them
l x x i x it looks like that would be 79
kind of like that number 21 on the shack
maybe the tva access points are numbered
and whatever the historical numerical
system is
now the craziest set of this trailer is
this red and white striped room
vines over growing everything i'm
assuming this is some kind of loki
throne room because there is a throne
with an
l over it but this place is a total [ __ ]
show there's a
shower stall there's lamps there's all
kinds of odds and ends it's like a
junkyard
it honestly kind of feels like an evil
lair that a future version of loki has
crafted for himself after
screwing over a bunch of timelines and
hoarding random crap from it but
by screwing up all those things like
1985 b
biff loki gets to be president in this
one also notice how one of the fighters
swings a weapon that looks like a
knockoff mjolnir like in this version
his thor
counterpart is this underling next clip
you'd better be ready
yeah yeah here is loki's amazing db
cooper jump with
heimdall catching him with bifrost that
explains it so it does kind of sound
like idris elba's heimdall is back alive
again which does make sense right
because in these alternate timelines
infinity war has not yet happened
and i love how they leave a few bills
behind the ones authorities would have
found in the river
perfect next clip
come on what did you expect
these flickering typefaces reflect the
alternate time periods and timelines to
show we'll hop in and out of there's
floor wallpaper
caked weathered stone scratch gold
wooden paneling but what i love about a
lot of these you can actually match
these letters together as there exists a
versions of the loki title where it's
all wooden or all emeralds it's kind of
like a rubik's cube with all these
different letters toggling around
trying to line up the typefaces but
unable to agree on a way to be and just
kind of giving up and being like i'm a
collage
whatever shut up now we end with loki
suited up with this loki for president
button
this is a nod to the 2016 vote loki
comic series in which loki runs for
president on the platform that he had
the guts to lie to everyone it's a great
series you gotta check it out now his
traitorous companions are delightfully
costumed one wears a license plate shirt
one is a helmet with silverware sticking
out the guy on the far right has a
helmet with
curved bike handlebars but then this
arcade game
my favorite detail in this trailer the
game
polybius so if you don't know about this
like db cooper polybius is another
element deeply rooted in american urban
legend specifically portland-related
ones the game itself
never existed or did it in the early
2000s internet forums began to talk
about how there was this game called
polybius in 1981
in the portland suburbs that caused
psychoactive and addictive effects in
whoever played it and that these game
boxes were later visited by mysterious
men and blacks who
gathered data from the machines problem
is there was no actual evidence of this
game
ever really existing it's just one of
these fun internet stories
but now we have the evidence it was loki
it was always loki
yeah polybius is just another great
example of how this loki series is
plugging in the god of mischief
into the mischief and unexplained
phenomena of history and i am here for
it look i'm gonna be breaking down
all the trailers we got at disney's
investor day but there is a lot to talk
about thank you for your patience check
out our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com subscribe to new
rockstars hit that notification button
follow me at ea boss following rockstars
see you next time
[Music]
you